what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch a movie that we
could not be more excited to watch that as
Evil Dead rise this is gonna be a groovy reaction
ladies and gentlemen I want to tell YouTube
something right away this is all fake everything
in this movie is performed by a professional
cast and crew audience was on it'll understand
it any violence is not real it's all okay
effects and we're gonna do what we can to
censor as much as we can to keep you happy
no it's all fake gotta say these things now
unfortunately but hey leave a like that'd
be very much appreciated use the Necronomicon
to subscribe that doesn't make any sense just
subscribe to do it I want to also give a special
sponsored shout out from our G fuel friends
ladies and gentlemen I'm gonna give you guys
a true download of everything here oh
here's how re-ups work when you get a re-up
for a sponsorship it's because wow they shouted
them out and look we got so many sales off
of it that we want to re-sponsor them again
we'll even give them a little bit more dough
this time that's not how it is at the real
rejects they just like me enough because they
know how much I love this product they even
lowered my race and I said that's fine just
send me more G fuel because apparently I can't
convince you guys enough just how great this
stuff actually is no matter how many videos
I'm drinking it in that are not sponsored
by g-fuel I just want to give you guys the
truth that I just work with them constantly
not for the money at all it's just because
of how much I love their product and everyone
who knows me in my personal life knows I really
mean it helps me with my energy and focus
throughout the day when it comes to filming
and editing and I work out at least five days
a week and every time before I work out unquestionably
I take one of their powders before I work
out as my pre-workout and they let me say
whatever I one what other brand would I want
to work with link in the description box special
promo code using reject Nation to get yourself
some g-fuel seriously do it if you haven't
done it already also uh Master thank you to
everyone who has been following us at our
patreon page becoming super sexy rejects especially
all the movie reactions we've been covering
and so many of you guys hopping on over there
pulling through action watch along for evil
deadrise available for super sexy rejects
I have a whole bunch of stuff exclusively
over there with reaction highlights and watch
along
[Music]
nice nice touch sweet
good self-aware joke meta you look like you're
gonna [__] a brick out sideways you could
have taken my head off you'd just scramble
your face up real good good to know I'll come
back later couldn't you go see if Jessica
is feeling any better she'll be fine I gave
her Klonopin so she can sleep off whatever
the [__] is wrong with her girl is such
a pain in the ass it's like the opposite of
2013. she's possessed you better wake up in
the next half hour or I'm going to be forced
to go drown that brainless meat puppet sorry
ass I think she's gonna do just that yep literally
the intense horror of my nightmare came over
me and the most Melancholy voice soft let
me in let me in it's well read
oh Jesus
[Applause]
whoa
whoa you're talking about an opening
oh my God what the hell happened
nasty Jessica
hahaha
whoa
oh gosh
wow it's still twitching
oh that was awesome what a title card so damn
that's a great shot let's go oh Goosebumps
that's different
pregnancy is the Real Horror ah it's movie
about parenting
making our own tattoo gun yeah I'm sure it'll
come into some violent play later you're not
going to any protest on your own
tell Danny to turn the music down I caught
it on that myself
damn the composition of these shots is awesome
yeah Cassie you better not have my scissors
don't got him Mom it's a great setting of
the stage uh your boyfriend's a weirdos you're
the weirdo
jeez okay that's gonna come to handy
they're a loving family I like this family
Dynamic it's very different yeah there's a
lot of artistic expression within the family
yeah especially the mom being like a tattoo
artist pretty cool
surprise [Laughter]
hahaha that's very real when this building
used to be a bank a teller got caught stealing
himself and if you walk around with coins
in your pockets his ghost hears the jingle
hunged himself Josh I only believe what I
can say get ready to see some [__] lady
yeah check out but I got your dad
oh he abandoned them Danny go take my car
and get pizza with your sisters one of the
hottest evilest looking mom I've ever seen
Perfect Two quadrant crossover why didn't
you tell me how I called you first time when
he told me he was leaving second the night
he moved out could I send a text I mean you
only called twice people don't answer the
phone these days you can sleep on the sofa
tonight
thank you the shrill's sound design you guys
gotta watch this with headphones oh yeah it's
like it's then Shivers everyone hey man that's
one of the Hallmarks of a good Evil Dead movie
is they are shrill hey Sally calling to say
hi and um me and Jay we are
there's no point in calling her back now
oh it's just tractor doing in the garage door
no it was priceless beverages
wow what a crazy shot Wowie
is this building like on a haunted ground
or something yeah it must be built on an Indian
burial ground there's a chainsaw on the side
of that truck oh is there yeah the tree trimming
truck
damn
it's an old Bank ball
that really is haunted it's cool it's usually
what's hidden in a cabin come on hang on what
you looking for money all right I'd be curious
as [__] too to see what's down here I
mean to be fair start up an urban exploring
YouTube channel
the Pope's Exorcist as like those guys Easter
eggs
[Music]
oh great distorted sound design
[Music] Jesus wept
right about now is when I lose interest [Laughter]
I go I'm not cool enough to stay there either
brave enough or stupid enough
here we go
foreign
[Music] can you hear up there quick Senator
hiding in the Ducks oh no don't kill the cat
13th floor is that then you never take the
elevator after a quake but you're on the 14th
floor lady Dan
my friend oh my friend now you've done it
[Applause] ah great looks like stop motion
yeah looks like Hagrid's magical creature
book
let's close it
I got stung by a jellyfish at the beach before
I don't like going underwater I don't think
there's any weird sea creatures in the tub
um I used to check
oh great shot
oh my God you're such a [__] don't
think
it's like he was meant to find this yeah I
would like to present you one of the disabled
volumes of naturum De Monta The Book of the
Dead the dead three volumes it's findings
are made of pure human flesh its passages
and etchings ached in blood blood the recitation
of which proclaimed to allow contact with
Supernatural forces that exist Beyond The
Thin veneer oh kid I know we got to get there
of a dip shall now commence reading aloud
the first of the spiritual Resurrection messages
and
uh
let's take it over
yes oh no
oh my [Applause] [Music] God
[__] it's coming right for her oh my God
oh
whoa cool holy [__] that was awesome this
is really really cool yeah it's almost inspiring
not the context but you know
oh
ah
[Music]
damn wow the aggression I knew I did not trust
those cables
huh
interesting
oh no no no no no no
oh damn
whoa cheese
gotta respect the cleverness on that sure
oh no how fun
huh
oh boy
it's like learning how to use the host yeah
I have the most beautiful drink we were together
sitting in a tall Forest the wind was clean
and the British team the Swedish smell man
huh smell it
Melodies oh oh I could think about was how
much I wanted to cut you all open and climb
inside your body so that we could stay one
happy family yep
[Music]
it's me oh
it's me I'm the evil it's me oh
foreign
[Music]
whoa
this is genuinely creepy I want Dad to come
home he will you said mom was gonna be okay
there would be I would love it if her dad's
Bruce Campbell
here's the Cameo you've been waiting for baby
I don't like being trapped everyone is on
edge enough without guns getting fired in
here I like that the other tenants aren't
like outwardly creepy like I like that there's
like a small communal aspect along with the
family
you're the one who always has the answers
no matter how busy you ever got you always
found time for me for everyone damn this dead
eye is milking it yeah I'm drumming up the
suspense
[Music] Ellie
calling to say hi Oh
pray on our guilt remember
whoa whoa what the [__] great use of the
phone
right on the eyeball yeah
oh it's alive standing up
oh yikes
oh this movie's so clever yeah
okay
oh I love it because it plays on the psychological
turmoil of the family too yeah like a lot
mommy's with the maggots now oh hey evil
oh God
that was mean get away from my bridge what's
happening to me sweetheart I don't know Mom
I do of course you do I'm free now free from
all you all you
oh no
no way whoa whoa whoa
let me kiss it better
oh Ellie [Music]
whoa what the [__] is going on whoa
I out oh
no Jesus Christ someone heimlich that poor
boy it is so dark
Evelyn malevolent as I've ever been
that's just scary
oh no [Music]
found his gun
great Style
I love it I love it that's amazing don't you
think mom looks just like one of those pictures
from that book you never should have stopped
this isn't my fault this is your fault
[Applause]
it's kind of his fault
ah jeez your gas bill is going to be ridiculous
[Music]
kill the little girl show me this movie means
business yeah it's not real to you kill a
kid
ah that tongue infection probably too yeah
oh no
oh God
oh no blood or ink looks like ink
fascinating Gorge how do they do that it looked
real well there you are
hey there cutie pie
I was just feeling sad about me and your dad
he's here now we're getting back together
isn't that right my darling oh she's good
interesting
she doesn't deserve to die oh gross open up
and let us in Cassie we can be a big happy
family again I hope so you don't look so good
mom nothing a big old hug and kiss from you
won't fix oh not now
no that's it do it for Mom and Dad [Music]
uh so do a kid come on
oh no
open a door like you open your legs you stinking
rubies
oh she's working through some [__] yeah
okay Stephanie will protect us right yeah
okay yep daughter's screwed that's too bad
yeah I feel bad for her it really had me convinced
the kids would be okay damn it what are you
looking at uh
oh
my God
I gotta kill the creepy crawlers that I got
inside my timing
oh those eyes oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't
like having things inside my tummy I don't
like this
do you antiba
[Music]
oh no for the love of God
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think I topped
the glass chewing for me man
now Basher heading she's half your size
oh
it came back and now it's got a real head
on it
great effect yeah
that poor little girl it's a great thing that
moment happened that was that came out of
it was a big surprise yeah
oh this video is brought to you by betterhelp.com
ah 35 bucks a month you can work your problems
out too this is what happened to us I'm not
gonna let that happen performance oh you did
a mom thing could be a good mom oh yeah you
know how to lie to kids
great delivery
I thought I should tie her up
just in case that is a good idea I want to
listen to that vinyl
it's too dangerous well I who gives a [__]
at this point you need disc three Hey listen
to the first and then he spoke the words on
the second I guess I'll start at the other
end then just in case yeah how does this get
to the cabin that's a great question I didn't
even possessed Cortez first rotting him from
the inside out
oh that last moment yeah
I feel it in my mouth
no no movie no movie don't do it I tried to
kill what
will this place
is she gonna catch fire or something
great oh she's smart
oh I didn't see that that's great oh she's
right there rotting and rage filled
wow that is a quiet dead body careful Danny
oh to the both of you
oh he stabbed her
ugh right in the bicep
of course
I told you you should have put the book back
Danny
cleanse it with fire
I know I tell you oh no no no no
hey
this horror will not stop that's right
that did nothing
that tickles I'm sorry
oh I will swallow your soul oh
[Music] what are you doing
what are you baby two Souls foreign
they would not I think they might yes
oh she had her scissors some of these shots
are pure sad Ramey oh yeah yeah
do you have a chainsaw how's your hand feeling
are you gonna be a mom
she made a choice the two lead actresses are
amazing yeah and such great contrast between
them
whoa
no no
yes blast it Boomstick yeah
oh damn that was scary that was a really good
jump skirt yeah and that floaty motion like
the old Evil Dead you have no idea what it's
like to bring a child into this world Stephen
oh
Mr Fonda
[Laughter] banshees everybody here dies by
Dawn bad dead by Don Evil Dead 2.
[Applause] evil dies tonight
[Music] damn this road has a solid grip on
escalation yeah
whoa
whoa what are they doing
so this was what it was like in The Shining
elevator I know that [__] was probably
so hard to get out what is it inside of her
why are they doing this they need her heart
or something oh forming into like a centipede
of sorts like a king rat evil deadite [Applause]
okay
goby with the cat [Music] wow
oh no
[Music]
oh overload it drop it
yep
great reference [Laughter] usually the blood
gets off at the second floor YouTube it's
not real blood corn syrup red food dye number
12.
oh let's see it let's see it guys gotta be
burning oh you said there was a chainsaw down
here well there was a picture of one on the
side of the van that had the wood chipper
on it but someone will find a real chainsaw
somewhere I bet those feel like Sam raybian
fetty Alvarez yeah all right
with with Lee cronin's like character based
the Buick it's a Buick great great there are
some Easter eggs in this movie yeah
huh
[__]
it's coming it's common
cool wow
oh that's amazing King corpse amazing this
is more efficient to combine to become that
then six spread out bodies cover more grounded
six spread up
oh this [__] is intense yeah
oh oh gross I love how they're handling the
perspective on this
oh what a great effect that is impressive
foreign
[Music] run Evil Dead run
oh no you gotta be kidding me Cassie
safada's tree surgery there's gotta be a chance
on the truck
wow
[Music]
yeah there is a chainsaw what the [__]
all I want is your little head baby girl oh
damn
get away from her you [__] come get some
come get some now
now grab the chainsaw
oh what a neat effect
oh that is so impressed fashion I can't get
over it yeah that's something new
I don't know no none of the chipper
I'll grab the chainsaw kick that Meg in the
teeth Jason Statham [Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
nice hey she [__]
[Music] aggressive it's like the end of 2013.
the blood rain and all help me baby boot only
my sister gets to call me that oh yes wow
oh no wow you know you really do look like
Mom and you're gonna fail miserably just like
her you stinking horrible
wow God the trick is always in the chainsaw
huh yeah I mean the the chipper helped but
oh is that chainsaw laughs
oh wow two final girls what a journey
I gotta take that with you yep
passing of the mantle this is gonna be a [__]
to get on YouTube
no idea what'll make the cut
blurry reactions
who is the dad please let me Bruce Campbell
that'd be awesome at this point they can make
any money but that's what I'm hoping for
us oh she's the one who went on vacation
okay I don't mean to be a downer or anything
but I was actually thinking you've taken a
rain check on
the pool not a chance I'm picking you up in
15. bye
wow it doesn't even smell down there yeah
I didn't knows any of the torrential blood
outpour
yep yep yep oh on all sides
oh
he wrote it too well done Lee Cronin
and robbed there's the Bruce Campbell cameo
snap Diggity yeah man oh wow these Pages too
oh wow that was well well done Dave garbett
aggressive it just kept building yeah no I've
made editing too seriously fantastic editing
yeah well there's like a point I don't know
like 45 minutes of the Moon I was like this
is not too bad like in terms of like the violence
and [__] yeah yeah yeah that was like
never mind this is really going on I mean
yeah kind of like just grips onto you at a
certain point it just like doesn't let go
yeah no yeah it's got this yeah really steady
build and then once it crosses a certain threshold
it does become like intensely you know carnivorous
and gory like I think pound for pound 2013
probably still has
slightly more slightly more in terms of just
like Gore set pieces you know but this one
had just all of that intensity and yeah it
it kind of filled the air in between in other
ways instead of just being Balls to the walls
but still having that you know quality yeah
that means 2013 one was so aggressive that
it was just kind of funny and how aggressive
it was that it wasn't necessarily like I I
really enjoy that one for just how hardcore
it is yeah uh but I wouldn't call it scary
like this one's actually like I was there
were times I was like this is really scary
this is a really scary situation and to not
have it play on like a remake of Evil Dead
and just to be it but have the familiar stuff
with the you know Necronomicon and they don't
they're never explicitly State the word deadites
yeah to have the deadites to have like the
makeup Jedi Kings Queen thing at the end was
awesome um but they they what they did such
an exceptional job ad um I think better than
like any of the Evil Dead movies I would any
of them movies I would say uh I I think the
one that they specifically credited as a dead
out in the credits um is the character work
here they they actually really get you to
care about the characters and I love that
they made the set of characters a different
kind of family dynamic because you it could
have easily just been the art types of what
you would normally see with a single mother
and the three children that she has but they
gave each one of them hobbies and interests
and personalities that are very different
than what you normally get in these kinds
of films yeah and right down to the mom too
both both the women as well um I felt like
a real family and and one where yeah like
you know everybody kind of has to pull a certain
amount of the weight in the house everyone's
a little probably more grown up than they
should have been at a certain age yeah but
none of the kids even a little girl none of
them are like overly precocious for their
age or some [__] like that you know yeah
they're not Hollywood kids yeah but then also
working through the I mean do you remember
the characters
the main the main character the the sister
Auntie Beth I think is yeah I think Beth an
evil Mom all right sake of conversation here
yeah um but Beth and her the [__] she's
working through it's kind of being judged
as someone who's like not mature and responsible
enough yeah but it's like these like subtle
some are very you know right on the nail digs
but then there's these this underlying tension
between them of someone who hasn't just grown
up enough and felt like judged by her sister
yeah but the way the movie managed to take
everything that works about Evil Dead and
not fully sacrificed the fun qualities about
it and nor get overly bogged down with wanting
to be like a heavy psychological piece either
it had this great middle line of keeping it
with that kind of energy that uh propulsive
quality throughout the whole thing but never
never succumbing to to one way or too much
to one way to the other I thought it was really
well balanced I was so impressed with the
way they did this because like after the 2013
one we we had Ash vs Evil Dead which just
took it right back to like the super campy
fun version yeah and then to like you couldn't
put like a Bruce Campbell Ash character in
this and get away with it I mean you could
but for what that Journey has evolved into
you need a new set of characters yeah and
to take that new set of characters who are
complete strangers to all this uh was was
a smart maneuver because it gave it something
that felt personal and the way they plan the
psychological turmoil uh was excellent that
was the part of it that I was so impressed
by was like damn this is a real like the ball
going you don't know what the hell's going
on yeah yeah no totally and and I think I
mean I I definitely sort of agree with everything
you just said and it's like yeah like you
could you could pair Ash up with Mia in in
in some context but this yeah I like how they've
managed to make this feel like its own thing
but also like it's still growing out of you
know everything that it came before I think
it's really interesting franchise that they've
built out of this because in some ways I do
think it is sort of like I mean like you know
when prey came out everyone was talking about
like all you need is like you know a couple
tenets of tone and you know the predator and
I feel like for Evil Dead all you need is
a couple tenets of tone because they're all
about these you know presences these beings
that just torment you
just the Flies yeah yeah
but no yeah it's like you know as long as
you have the book and as long as you have
you know these tormenting you know just gleefully
maniacally evil demonic spirits you can kind
of do anything inside of that framework I
feel like and I think that's the smart thing
and what's cool about this is like you said
this feels like it's definitely how the tradition
of Sam Raimi people are getting slimed left
and right like and it certainly seems like
this would had to have been a sticky and and
like uncomfortable adventure for the actors
involved but then it has the aggression and
the tension of the fetty Alvarez take and
then I think what Lee Cronin brings to this
which is really nice is at least watching
that one film of his which I believe is called
a hole in the ground uh you know like that
I feel like that's kind of one of those a24
movies that that has that created helped to
create that idea of like the really intense
trailer but it's more just like a taught psychological
kind of horror-ish drama and that's you know
like about a a young woman trying to you know
like raise like can't remember it's like her
little brother or something like that but
you know he brought this intimate family quality
into a place that now has all those satisfying
elements that you know a movie like that maybe
sets you up to think will be there but aren't
as much the priority whereas here you know
you have the benefit of you got to go extreme
for Evil Dead and two you have the sensibility
of compassion toward who this family is and
it doesn't do too much you know reveling in
like oh we got to build the story like I thought
it moved at a really nice clip but it gave
you a full portrait of who these people are
and what's going on and then you know they
stumble across the book the way anybody stumbles
across the book and I like that you know they
borrow that idea of I guess there are three
volumes so they can kind of you know you've
got the one in the woods you've got this one
maybe there's another one out there and then
Army of Darkness I mean they have three of
them on hand in some way although the other
two are like fake or whatever but but yeah
like this had such beautiful like low light
photography and like all these split diopters
and some of them are used in the way you're
used to seeing them in a horror movie but
many of them I thought you know created I
thought they used them across the tone instead
of just like here's one really cool shot it's
like no we're gonna do what's in the foreground
what's in the background guide your eye around
like it's just so engaged in how the filmmaking
is communicating all this stuff and yeah it's
like I thought this one did nicely I associate
Evil Dead movies with being shrill and mocking
in a lot of ways and and you know kind of
always out to like poke you and make you squirm
and I thought this one was cool because as
compared to the other ones yeah you do have
those moments of breath and Air in between
and you do have at least a more sort of gradual
feeling build to yeah this intense chaos and
it's like contained it's like a bottle movie
in so many ways yeah and it does a good job
at getting you a sense of that they have a
chance at escaping because they all you got
all you know is they it's got to get out of
the building yeah like as long as we're out
of the building they're fine yeah and it's
that that real difficult journey of just getting
to that parking garage and exiting yeah and
I think they do a really they excel at that
uh with really creating what the environment
is and getting you an understanding of of
the layout and never relying too much on things
like yeah it has these like claustrophobic
qualities but because but more than claustrophobic
it just feels like really discontained and
because of how contained it is you it doesn't
what I like is that it doesn't rely on the
claustrophobia I just relies on this is there's
not much where you can really run to to get
it to get out of the situations that you're
in I really do think that even if you haven't
seen um Evil Dead before like you really don't
need to and they they just they have some
like fun winks and nods and I feel like for
people who like Evil Dead they'll they'll
enjoy this movie hopefully I mean it seems
like they did right I feel like people aren't
this movie's been killing it I mean yeah it's
it's made huge money and everybody who's is
a fan seems quite pleased I mean you know
everyone's debate is comes down to like oh
where would you rank it but everyone seems
pretty enthused overall I think it's a one
of the better ones in terms of like an actual
movie I mean in terms of like a well-rounded
movie with like characters that you all around
care about in some ways this is the most of
a film yeah I know exactly yeah because because
like I love the 2013 version as well but you
know like some of the dialogue in that could
be better blah blah blah whereas this you
know had a thoughtfulness about it and yeah
I really liked all the family members and
two they got me kind of off guard because
I should have assumed most everybody would
die but at first I was like okay so you've
got these other tenants to add to the body
count but no I mean you lose most of the family
you know except for the the the small child
you know the little Cassie and uh you know
and and they they flirt I think they flirted
with the line nicely on certain things like
I was like are they gonna rip are they gonna
rip this kid out of her stomach right now
it would have been a little too much for me
I thought they did a good job at messing with
the audience because I mean to me I would
have been like it's a little too much a little
too farther yeah yeah because then you're
jumping up a different caliber into your daredevilish
your geek show Human Centipede Serbian film
yeah and then that's the thing too is you
have to figure out what is going to be disgusting
make people score make people want to look
away but not be like that is the magic I think
is is finding the fun times intensity that
doesn't cross over into just ah this is unpleasant
because I keep it creative like even the gore
gags are very creative I was surprised by
how uh creative they were yeah I think you
know like because sometimes with the 2013
when it's like I don't want to make it something
we're just sliding it sometimes it does feel
like they're just really mean and it's practical
yeah sure you know where here like it it does
get mean and like vicious yeah but it never
they always found a way to capture it in a
way that was still thought out even with the
glass bit yeah you know like the way they
mess with the lighting even on the the swallowing
and then poking out I think that shot's in
the trailer I just forgot about it yeah um
it got overshadowed by the cheese grater I
don't know the glass one's the one anytime
that you a character hoop like chews glass
that already like messes me up yeah I feel
it in my mouth it's not good yeah that already
is like disturbing enough to me yeah they
just get like hammering at home there but
it does respected I think we're in a day and
age now where they like kill off kids and
stuff big respect for killing those kids you
know Halloween kills didn't it for Halloween
2018 whatever whatever it was something about
when you do that you go it's movies [Music]
yeah I want you to know they'll kill off anyone
kids are unsafe here um well and this had
tributes and Easter eggs in a way that I thought
was nice because they weren't ever really
flying them too far in your face I mean you
know chainsaw is gonna chainsaw especially
though is that's the one where you you that
has to happen but if you had no idea it would
still be cool and fun and a nice surprise
it's like I feel like the most overt Easter
egg really is The Shining elevator yeah and
then the rest is you know stuff if it's like
they're chanting dead by Dawn and it's like
if you know you know but if you don't it's
still Eerie and creepy and it's a part of
the scene you know it's not just hey remember
it's not member berries as much you know as
people like to say yeah I kind of feel like
the opening scene actually really helps with
setting a really good tone for the adventure
you're about to go on otherwise I might have
just felt like too serious of a psychological
drama yeah but having that opening scene at
at the lake and then even making fun of the
Drone shot yeah so good I love how they just
decided to show that to us yeah um and then
reminded us of we're evil that comes from
like clearly there's reverence for the Evil
Dead franchise here it doesn't just feel like
a director stepping and going I just want
to make my own you know and they do they make
it their own but they do it with honoring
what came before it it really does feel collateral
like with fetty Alvarez and now with Lee Crone
in both it's felt like they really put time
into figuring out who's voice can jibe again
with what's come before keep some of that
but also bring something else to help expand
on this and I thought yeah they they seem
very conscientious in who they choose and
I mean Lee cronin's been out there being like
I got four more ideas for movies what do you
want to see next so like I would be excited
to see him return but I would also be just
as excited to see some new blood you know
take the reins and I think that will help
Evil Dead like it's one of the most consistent
franchises I think you can and weirdly one
of the most inconsistent because whenever
the one comes out it's a success amongst fans
especially and then they go can't do a follow-up
sorry yeah we're gonna wait another five five
ten years 23rds it's been 10 years like yeah
they had the show in between two and that
show was very beloved but that got canceled
yeah um and like it just didn't get enough
viewership for and I know Bruce Campbell has
talked about specifically on the the sh what
was it stars specifically put it on Stars
they thought might have been a mistake for
the kind of viewership starts expected to
generate for producing that show yeah I bet
um and that's where a lot of the default that's
where a lot of the fault of what viewership
comparison kind of came down to like it was
actually got good views but not enough for
what stars wanted yeah and I mean I imagine
like I got Stars just for that and then Evil
Dead the 2013 obviously like that did not
uh that did well and they wanted to do part
two but that never happened and and then uh
Army of Darkness wasn't a hit and it's gained
like a cold following like it is a really
consistent franchise but in terms of like
follow-ups I'm like I never I never hold out
I'm just like we'll see you'll be like it's
the greatest responses movie has been as successful
as it is too I'm like who knows knowing this
franchise probably never see a sequel oh yeah
well and that's the funny part too is I mean
I hope the theatrical release has helped because
that was the other narrative was like oh this
was originally intended just to go right to
streaming so so we watched it how they originally
intended but you know they put it in theaters
and it is I don't know if it's done better
box office than 2013 but I get this that's
just the vibe I've gotten because it's over
150 million or more now you know well this
movie I think with evil dead too you also
need um Evil Dead as well I mean I think the
people that you need to have great practical
effects like it relies so much on that and
even with something like Army of Darkness
which would as wacky as that film gets they
use as much practical as they can oh yeah
and I I think this movie also generates a
lot of great practical effects and the performances
are incredibly strong between the mom who
turns but like prior to her being a mom the
moment Sutherland or whatever she's she's
actually the world human being yeah and I
like the tribute to the The Vines wrapping
around but they do it without elevator Accords
clever and then her as the evil mama is the
main villain for this I thought was really
smart because usually the first one who turns
is they're just trapped or incapacitated in
some way yeah and then to make her the head
villain I thought was a neat structure oh
yeah because like dead like the the Evil Dead
implied by the title are all about just torture
and torment and yeah what better a way to
really make people suffer than to pervert
the entire family Dynamic from the top down
yeah and and yeah make that just as mean as
possible and two like I loved their take on
the book and that's the thing too is like
the book kind of changes like it doesn't have
a face in this one but it's got the teeth
on the binding and then you get that foreshadowing
of what the king deadite is gonna or queen
deadite is going to look like in the pages
and then they sort of shoot around it for
the most part until you know the very end
to let you kind of fill in the blanks based
on just how horrific the images are the old
recording I thought was great I love the record
gag was was fun and uh yeah and just seeing
that you know writhing human-based monstrosity
brought to life was something new that I I'm
not used to seeing in these I feel like they
they often go for body horror and they distort
and and make you know pain for the human form
but to see yeah this like fused together creature
it was like another that's something I feel
like you could play off of and and enhance
going forward you know and do even more of
those kinds of things all right John lay take
the reins um I put it out on our community
post I mean for me I gave it a 9.5 out of
10. sure I'm with you there and and there
must be like some kind of random ass Bruce
Campbell thing so if somebody caught it Enlighten
us great music generally take the reins on
this oh goody got some question I don't know
if there are questions see 97 comments but
um oh go ahead I said we're gonna do a spoiler
talk um so let's just take it away what's
the top one the top one the opening title
card hits hard so good and this is from Michael
legere I hope I'm saying your name right which
practical effect was your favorite I really
like the sequence with the sheet oh I mean
it's got to be the centipede yeah whatever
you call that they're like stunt performers
involved too like I don't I I would love to
know how they brought that to life there's
a thing like that I don't want to ruin it
for John in something but there's a thing
in something if you guys know me you might
know what I'm referring to but yeah there's
a thing uh that I don't want to roam but I
was like oh [__] man if they were able
to bring that's left then they could bring
it yeah I don't want to say too much but um
yeah I think that was a a fantastic effect
and oh God there's a lot of great practical
effects there are tons of yeah I mean you
could just sit there and name them all I was
very struck it's not maybe the most obvious
one but I was very struck when she starts
like bleeding ink out of her eyes especially
like and I'm sure they can erase stuff but
it didn't look no it didn't look like CG Goose
so like however they rigged that was was quite
impressive and I mean like that that nasty
vomit gag like Ugh uh let's see here Lee Cronin
had stated there are four options for where
the Francesca goes come from Rob it's equal
to this one with Beth again at the center
um explanation exploration of the vinyls having
a John Wick Style movie with the priests that
read for the book Cleanup Crew the apartment
complex II go back to the cabin in the woods
where would you like to see the franchise
go next uh I think it would be an interesting
personally I think it would be a more interesting
experiment to do beth again at the center
because I think with evil other than when
you have the show I think part of what makes
Evil Dead cool is you only get just enough
mythology yeah and I don't know I I don't
really care to do the back of the apartment
again uh and then back to the cabin in the
woods like that you're you're retreading at
that point yeah which I'm sure would be entertaining
as hell but you are just retreading at that
point yeah um so a sequel to one with Beth
again at the center allows for uh the evolution
of the character you can even do little bit
of a time Jump if you want to or or you could
do something really interesting where you
just pick it up moment the same night yeah
and just like really keep it I mean yeah like
narratively I think that would be interesting
because I was always one to be like please
let's do Evil Dead 2 with Mia uh so to see
Beth back at the center I think would be good
I think the the John Wick style is a bit of
a reach it could be cool I'll throw my hat
in for the rec2 style just because I think
that could be an interesting way to carry
it on you could get Beth back but have a new
set of people affected by this and then maybe
Take It Outside the apartment or something
why don't we go with this one John ooh the
video Club random massive fan of the franchise
I like both 2013 remake and this new one but
don't you think that in these more serious
tone without the style and humor of Raymond
Campbell like in the uh oh original trilogy
original trilogy there you go and the series
it becomes just another horror movie missing
that unique characteristic that made Evil
Dead stand out um I wouldn't say that at all
I mean like I certainly understand missing
the campiness and the Bruce Campbell more
Three Stooges style comedy and that presence
of like you know the guy who is a total braggart
but is also inept in various ways until he
you know Rises but I think first one was pretty
serious too yeah I think people forget that
and and I I think that what they've done nicely
in 2013 and in this new installment is they
have honed in on some of just I think the
more core Elements which is yeah it's that
element of gleeful torment that mean you know
Punchy energy it's wet it's gross it's practical
but it's like 2013 and this one have that
quality where they're not as outwardly fun
and funny but you can tell behind the camera
whoever is directing this is like giggling
at what they're putting these poor cast folks
through yeah so I think they still maintain
the the style but there's a certainly a divide
between the OT and the new Ray Mar saw the
movie loved it Alyssa Sutherland as Ellie
was the best part of the movie hands down
her facial expressions are incredible however
what did you think about the protagonist Beth
my only problem with her character is that
there's nothing that really gets me invested
in her to care much we're introduced to her
find out she's pregnant and it has a little
impact because they know nothing about her
I just wish we got time with her to actually
get behind her character what'd you all think
thanks uh I feel like in this movie it is
her journey of deciding whether or not to
become a mom that was sort of what I was picking
up on I feel like she was showing up to there
to talk about maybe getting rid of the baby
which should I keep it or not yeah yeah and
and then you know she sees like the struggles
of what it's like to have and like going to
see her sister specifically who has kids and
get an experience of of that you know um and
then you know I even got a gift for the dad
and so she gets this experience of like oh
here's what it's like being a ma oh well if
the dad leaves what if I don't have the support
and then as she goes through this journey
with having the kid with like trying to protect
the children and stuff uh I I feel like that's
her deciding I am good enough to become a
mom like I I can become a mom so I thought
it was interesting because
yeah but I think too you learn a lot about
her through the family yeah there's that choice
that what the little girl asks her are you
gonna be a mom and she and in that moment
she's going I'm going to be yes and I think
part of her saying that is her going I'm also
going to adopt you and get you the hell out
of here yeah yeah yeah and and and I do think
that yeah even though there are a lot of other
characters to focus on I think we do learn
about her and what her struggles are and what
her life is through her with the other characters
so I I didn't feel like anything was missing
really um kind of covered that kind of covered
that I feel like we should do at least one
more yeah
um okay let's take this one the bearded cenophile
uh John take it away sure what do you make
of the irony that the thing that brings Danny
the most Joy DJing and using his turntables
and spinning some sweet LCD sound system jams
ultimately destroys almost all of his family
because he plays The Book of the Dead record
on his record player I found that fascinating
yeah I mean early on that like there was a
moment part way through where I was expecting
that the all three of the kids might live
but then it started to make a lot more sense
especially after you know the first daughter
goes like yeah like part of these movies are
are punishing and certainly Danny is punished
for his passion for his passion and his curiosity
yeah yeah so I thought that was like without
being like super on the nose I thought it
made for a good gag with the record player
and the like when he can't get the needle
off of it and stuff like that and uh and yeah
a good piece of irony tragic irony for that
character no it's tragedy that's his love
and it punishes him and in the end yeah because
you know like I I think the whole thing with
Awakening the dead leads to a lot of the time
being like what a bunch of freaking idiots
yeah you know but this is LA and out here
in L.A you know like yeah don't get me wrong
there's like a lot of different religions
out here and and people who are non-believers
that's also very prevalent out here like there's
a lot of people who don't believe in God and
stuff so to me for a kid to just go down there
and find some spooky [__] but be like
oh it's cool we can actually sell I I bought
what he was doing yeah I bought his curiosity
with it all and they were wondering about
the Vault the building itself is run down
anyway so it's like the they're they turned
down yeah like the basement in that too it's
like oh this is someone might just bury this
in rubble if we don't kind of look around
in here yeah yeah um but hey guys uh thank
you for all who uh submitted questions next
time I just gotta remember um I like the glossy
slick look for this Evil Dead film by the
way just me just someone who asked that I
I like it I think I think when you have I
think that's what helps separate well okay
all right Justin says do you think this is
too glossy slick for an evil dead film I personally
miss a gorilla filmmaking early installments
I think what's really cool is you know when
Sam Raimi and Bruce Campbell are doing it
yeah is when you have more of that style when
even with the show like there's a certain
type of like I ever kind of just having fun
with winging it a little bit Yeah like it's
it's composed but there's there's a looseness
to it yeah um where the other Evil Dead can
Branch off with these other versions that
it's like as long as you keep like an economic
on deadeyes and whatnot um then then you could
have more of this like glossy cinematic appeal
look to it so I think it's neat when you can
have kind of both sides you know and that's
one of the unique things about the franchise
to me but guys what did you think about Evil
Dead rise thank you all those submitted some
questions we'll get to those a little quicker
next time this was an experiment so I kind
of forgot about it uh but I was like oh [__]
we need to remember to answer the questions
I totally use um I totally put that out there
and I was like I'm so caught up in reviewing
it no I'll remember next time to get to it
quicker but thank you guys so much uh leave
your thoughts down below uh be sure to subscribe
you can follow us on patreon to get a g fuel
once again and hey we'll uh catch you all
very soon [Music]